this might truly be the most interesting
Republican primary that I have ever been
involved in covering by far even more
than 2016.
we now have video of Ron DeSantis on the
Fox news program hosted by Jesse Waters
and Jesse Waters brings up to DeSantis
Trump's increasingly frequent uh and
unhinged attacks against him and for now
DeSantis approach has been to take the
high road I don't know that that will
work but that has been desantis's
approach so far let's take a look at how
DeSantis responded yesterday when
confronted with the recent comments of
Donald Trump all right well former
president Donald Trump definitely
thinking about you uh you haven't said a
lot uh I know you've heard what he said
and you you can see this Collision is
coming can't you yeah
well look Jesse I mean you know he used
to say how great of a governor I was and
then I win a big victory and all of a
sudden you know he had different
opinions and so you could take that for
what it's worth but you know at the end
of the day I think one of the reasons
I've been successful as Governor uh is I
don't really pay attention a lot of the
background noise I mean you know he's
obviously a big a big fish but I get
attacked all the time from every
different angle and you either put
points on the board or you don't and so
I just focus on delivering the wins and
I think we've done a pretty good job of
following through on our promises so
this is super interesting there's two
interesting things here one is this is
the first willingness we're really
seeing from DeSantis to actually go at
Trump now you might say David that's
very light all he's saying is Trump used
to praise DeSantis and now he doesn't
yeah right but that's one of the big
things that Trump does and Trump doesn't
like being called out for it which is he
he doesn't praise or criticize People
based on whether whether he genuinely
thinks they're doing a good job or not
he Praises or criticizes People based on
how they treat Trump and whether what
they're doing is useful to Trump so
first thing there that the santis is
doing is calling out Trump's hypocrisy
and how Trump's opinion of people just
waivers based on what's good for Trump
secondly the other uh interesting thing
here that we are seeing is that DeSantis
is starting to lay the groundwork
for approaching this campaign
from the perspective of Trump's just
like another guy and he even says in
there I get attacked all the time
and while he concedes Trump's a big fish
he is basically suggesting Trump is no
different in any serious way than
everybody else who attacks him and Trump
doesn't see himself as being like
everybody else Trump wants to be exalted
and held above everybody else so desant
is saying I get attacked all the time by
all sorts of people he's just grouping
Trump in with everybody else which Trump
is not going to like now and you know
DeSantis talks about his wins and I
mentioned this in the last segment a
little bit Florida 12th highest in Cova
death rate per capita it's completely
mediocre in terms of crime it's right in
the middle completely mediocre on Health
Care completely mediocre on
infrastructure not one of the worst
nowhere near the best you know it's sort
of like Florida were way better than
Mississippi and Arkansas on all of these
metrics but we're nowhere near New York
or Massachusetts or Connecticut on any
of this stuff and I like Florida as a
place to go but it's not like they have
a great record for DeSantis to actually
write home about his accomplishments are
things that are virtue signals as I
mentioned before you know the Banning
CRT we're going to have wrestling
matches really early in covid because we
we want to and taking control of Disney
because it went woke the anti-woke act
the don't say gay bill that's the sort
of thing that DeSantis is known for one
other funny moment from this interview
it really seemed like Jesse waters for a
moment thought DeSantis was going to
announce his run on his program didn't
happen I mean you're obviously running
for president you got the book you're
going around the country doing these
events I mean what's going on here
Governor right I have
I've got uh well I'm proud of I'm proud
of what we've done in Florida a lot of
people ask me how you do it yeah but
I've got over the next few months I've
got a big legislative session we just
want a big re-election Victor I've made
a lot of promises we're going to deliver
on those promises so uh finish reading
the book I'm happy to come back and
discuss that with you but I'd like to
come back over the next three months and
discuss a lot of these legislative wins
that we're having for example though
we're going to make sure our
universities are so now he's just going
to talk about something else he doesn't
actually want to address uh the uh
presidency thing are you from this Dei
ideology and that's going to be a great
Bill to be able to sign here coming up
very soon all right well former
president Donald Trump definitely
thinking about you okay so then we get
into the the thing we looked at before
okay so descent is not ready to announce
yet he's starting to criticize Trump but
there's something even more interesting
that the DeSantis uh campaign the
DeSantis Administration did let's talk
about that next
one of our sponsors is paired the app
for couples every day paired gives you
and your partner questions quizzes games
to have fun to stay connected to deepen
your conversations and get to know each
other better what's great about it is
you don't even have to be in the same
room especially with the baby right now
my girlfriend and I are quite busy and
paired really helped us to stay
connected you get a daily question to
answer you can't see your partner's
answer until you answer yourself and
their questions about everything
relationship life intimacy other things
and all of the exercises were developed
by academic psychologists and expert
relationship therapists as well
questions like what makes you feel lucky
in your relationship great when you want
to remember and have gratitude a really
great thing what's an activity you could
try together this month actually gets
people thinking about things to do it
can go in really funny directions as
well but it just always feels like time
well spent head over to paired.com
Pacman for a seven day free trial and 25
off a subscription the link is down
below